wir sind Brüder wir sind Schwestern so
etwas gibt es nur in Köln eine
Kirchengemeinde außer Rand und Band ein
fast der laufensgottesdienst und das
auch noch mit Stars des Kölner Karnevals
dabei sind zum Beispiel Kasalla Stefan
brings Stefan knittler und der
97-jährige Ludwig sebus und dieser
karnevalsgottesdienst findet dieses Jahr
zum dritten Mal statt und ist damit in
Köln Tradition und dabei spielt die
Musik eine ganz besondere Rolle los
geht's
[Musik]
Dankeschön auch das kann ein guter Zweck
sein ein karnevalsgottesdienst und der
hat eine ganz besondere
Entstehungsgeschichte der
Pastoralreferent der St agnes-kirche
Peter Otten erzählt wie das Ganze
begonnen hat die Idee ist drei Jahre alt
als Corona kam ist ja Karneval ins
Wasser gefallen und uns haben ganz viele
Menschen damals
2021 angesprochen haben gesagt es gab
noch nie ein Jahr wo wir den Karneval so
vermisst haben und dann haben wir
überlegt ja wenn nichts erlaubt ist es
war ja nicht erlaubt und Festivitäten
Gottesdienst
Format finden wo wir die Musik in den
Mittelpunkt stellen und die Kraft der
Musik in den Mittelpunkt stellen und das
haben wir dann zum ersten Mal gemacht
vor zwei Jahren
und durch glückliche Umstände weil die
Techniker nicht zu tun hatten konnten
wir das ins Internet betrieben und
hatten 60.000 Zuschauer im ersten Jahr
und dann haben wir gedacht wir machen es
einfach noch mal haben es dann letztes
Jahr noch mal gemacht und das machen was
zum dritten Mal und dann ist es in Köln
schon eine Tradition im letzten Jahr
drehte sich alles um den Krieg in der
Ukraine denn in Köln kriegt man Spaß
ernst und sogar Religion ganz entspannt
unter ein Dach dieses Jahr das Thema
heißt sing mich ein Haus auf Kölsch auf
Hochdeutsch sing mich nach Hause
halten Satz der das Schöne und Karneval
wunderbar zusammenfasst also sing mich
nach Hause sing ein Lied dass mich
sozusagen nach Hause in die Heimat
begleitet
und
das zeigt also was für ein wunderschönes
Gefühl der Karneval ist also es wird im
Heimat gehen Ludwig sebus
97-jährig in Kölner original
wahrscheinlich der älteste jeck der noch
lebt Alter Krätze in Sänger
der hat bei Schuhen euch in der
Kölnerinnen eine tolle Rede gehalten und
zum Zusammenhalt gegen
Rechtsradikalismus aufgerufen und
sich daran erinnert wie es ihm selber
ergangen ist im Krieg der wird kommen
und eine eine Predigt halten und die
Lieder die gesungen werden die werden
sich im weitesten und dem Meeren sind
halt um den Gedanken der Heimat ist nach
Hause kommen das
Wohlfühlens der Gemeinschaft der Comunio
drehen so und das wirklich Besondere
daran ist dass hier die Gemeinde
Mitglieder den Gottesdienst organisiert
und auch den Livestream finanzieren es
soll nämlich ein Gottesdienst für alle
sein auch wer der Kirche den Rücken
gekehrt hat soll mitfeiern können und
gerade in Köln soll es ja die ein oder
den anderen geben ja der fühlt sich dann
hier wieder willkommen
dieser Gottesdienst hat einerseits schon
traditionelle Elemente es wird aus dem
Evangelium vorgetragen es wird Fürbitten
geben die Fürbitten können die Menschen
per SMS in den Gottesdienst reinstecken
es wird ein Segen geben wenn das
Vaterunser beten aber ja was anders ist
als bei anderen Gottesdiensten ist die
Sprache also wenn man mit Musikern
spricht auch mit Kirchenmusikern sagen
die das geistliche Lied ist aus dem
Volkslied entstanden also ich habe mit
dem Fachexperten mal gesprochen er sagt
ganz ganz viele Bach Kantaten ganz viel
was Bach geschrieben hat kommt aus der
Volkskunst und ich finde die
Karnevalsmusik gerade die rheinische
Musik greift das unglaublich schön aus
also und ich finde sie sind die die
keine was Musik ist in der Lage
komplizierte theologische Texte ganz
einfach auszudrücken und insofern freuen
wir uns und das ist irgendwie auch das
was ich am besten dran finde dass wir
darüber natürlich auch Menschen
erreichen die unsere sprach nicht mehr
verstehen also sing mich nach Russ wie
kann man schöner vom Himmel singen sagt
Agnes wird damit am 13 Februar quasi zum
Himmel auf Erden und es sollen auch
wieder tausende über Youtube daran
teilnehmen können und dafür benötigt die
Initiative noch Unterstützung mehr Infos
dazu gibt es hier oder in der
Videobeschreibung bis dann bleibt dran